guys the wedding was fabulous
first of all
you know
i am i guess you kind of get a sense of
kind of how i am from watching the
podcast and stuff like that and you know
i'm a you know i i about things
and i you know i have strong opinions
about things and sometimes i'm a little
too serious about some things you know
and i've kind of had to address just a
party the wedding it's just for the wife
you know it's just for the girl it
doesn't matter you know what i mean like
it's like for a guy you're just gonna
show up and whatever
but i got to tell you it was the
greatest day of my life it really was
it was like emotional i'm i was like i
cried so many times it was
seeing all my friends there and
everything it was just it really was a
magical day
[Music]